-Our first guest, tonight,
is an Emmy-winning
and Tony-nominated
comedian and writer
who you know from her work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
"30 Rock," "Girls5eva,"
and "Mean Girls,"
both the movie
and the Broadway musical.
She's the co-creator
of "Mr. Mayor,"
which airs Tuesday nights
at 8:30 p.m., here on NBC.
Please welcome back to the show,
our very good friend,
Tina Fey, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi!
-It is so good to see you!
-It's so nice to see you.
-I've seen you in person
a few times.
-Yeah.
-The last time you were on
the show was via Zoom.
-Yes.
-And your daughter Penelope
did that lovely thing
that was happening in
the early days of the pandemic.
She just fully crashed
the interview.
-She just fully entered
the Zoom, yeah.
-Yeah. And was not very
complimentary to either of us.
-No, she entered the Zoom.
I believe she was wearing, like,
a Colonial-lady outfit.
-Yeah.
-Because -- as one does.
And then she just got behind me
and just went --
[ Laughter ]
And did, like, a slow...
-Yeah.
-...slow exit.
You know.
-Does she like her time
on camera?
She did seem very comfortable.
-She was a little too
comfortable at that time, yeah.
Yeah, they both are.
You know, Penelope ended up
on "Girls5eva."
But, yeah, Alice and Penelope
are both really funny.
They have a great
sense of humor.
I am embargoed from speaking
about them on talk shows.
-Gotcha.
-Because that's what happens.
Like, they're such a gold mine
for stories, at first.
-Yes.
-And then someday,
Axel's gonna come to you and be
like, "I'm the Lobby Baby?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Really, Dad?"
-It's gonna be a problem.
-"I'm the Lobby Baby?"
And you're like, "Uh, well..."
and you have to backpedal.
[ Laughs ]
-I'm just hoping Netflix won't
be around by then, you know?
-Well --
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, can we talk about this?
Are you allowed
to talk about that?
Yeah, okay. So, that is --
-Okay.
-Again, back in the days
when I used to talk about them,
this is the other thing that,
like, such a --
such a weird New York childhood
that our kids have that like...
-Yes.
-my older daughter is 16 now,
and she was talking
to another teenager,
and he was saying like, "Yeah,
it was hard 'cause, you know,
like, I got made into a meme."
She's like, "Yeah,
I was a meme once, too."
Like, kids are growing up, like,
being like,
"Yeah, I was memed once."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Oh, yeah."
And I don't --
And I knew she had been a meme
when she was little.
And I don't know when she
found out she was a meme.
-Right,
'cause you didn't tell her.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
Because it wasn't my fault.
But she was a fantastic meme.
-It's a really good meme.
Anybody --
Does anyone remember this meme?
What's your camera?
-Here, right over there.
Go over there.
-I don't work here.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, that's a fantastic meme.
Even this, I might still get in
trouble for reshowing this.
-Yeah.
-Oh, that camera, sure.
-But she looks really good.
Now is that --
Can we assume -- is that you?
-That's me looking
just bedraggled.
-Yeah.
-And I think part of --
part of the meme was, like,
she was living high on the hog,
and I was bedraggled.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for
cropping me out of that.
-I do love it.
I mean, it is --
Somebody really nailed it
when they were like,
"This girl's gonna be a meme."
-And there were ones, like,
they put that next to, like,
Michael Cera or, like,
next to, like,
Happy Leo DiCaprio.
It's a whole thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, you did a thing
that I think is very kind
of a parent to do.
You allowed your children
to get a pet.
What kind of pet do you have?
-Oh, yeah, I own
a bearded dragon now, Seth.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Who wanted the bearded dragon?
-Penelope was very...
-Okay.
-...is into -- very much into
the lizard, reptile lifestyle.
-And she was specific
of this one?
-Yes. Um, [bleep] YouTube
will tell you a lot about
different kinds of
lizards and stuff.
And --
[ Laughter ]
-What kind -- is it
a boy lizard, a girl lizard?
-It's -- their name is Herman.
-Okay.
-And they come --
they're like this big.
-Okay.
-And then it's, like, you know,
those little sponge capsules
that you put in water,
and then it's like -- bwaaarrr!
He's already this big.
I think, from what I'm told,
bearded dragons, they don't
have a gender at first.
-Okay.
-Their genitals develop
over time.
-Gotcha.
-We decided that their name
is Herman, no matter what.
-Okay.
-None of us is really into,
like, digging for the genitals.
-Right?
[ Laughter ]
-We're just kind of like,
"Whatever."
It doesn't matter.
-Right.
-They live alone.
[ Laughter ]
In a tank.
-Yeah.
-So -- And --
-Yeah, Herman's not filling out
a Tinder profile or anything.
-Exactly, Herman's not looking
to meet people.
-[ Laughs ]
-By the way, my mom
is staying with me right now.
And guess what --
she's gonna say,
"Why did I see your elbows?"
And I'm gonna say,
"I don't know."
-Yeah.
-Did you like them, though?
-It's great.
By the way, you came out,
and I saw it,
and I thought to myself,
"That is a wonderful
sartorial choice."
-Yeah, thanks.
-'Cause that's fashion
right there.
-Fashion.
-Yes.
-But that is a very big asterisk
that your mother
is staying with you.
-Oh, this is not for anyone's --
Anyone's mom
is gonna be like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
-That is her "Euphoria,"
that you're wearing that.
-This is her "Euphoria."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm not gonna understand it!
I'm not gonna
try to understand it!
I won't even look at it."
[ Laughter ]
Um, lizards, yeah.
-Yeah.
So you -- I'm gonna move --
Can I move off from lizards?
Do you have more to add?
-Please.
No, I will say that the only
thing about lizards is that you
also then get to be the owner
of 60 or 70
live crickets every week also.
-Oh.
Now, I'm assuming
these are not around
for the lizard's companionship.
-They are --
No, they're their food, yeah.
-So you get 60 crickets a week.
-Yeah.
-Do the crickets --
-You have to go get them.
-Okay.
-And then they sing all night
in your apartment.
And it's so sad,
because they don't know
they're on death row.
[ Laughter ]
They're singing like
they're in Central Park.
[ Laughter ]
Death row.
-That is heartbreaking.
-It's heartbreaking.
-'Cause you know.
-I know what's going down.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I don't know what kind of
genitals Herman has,
but I know what's gonna go down
with those crickets.
-You know he's got a mouth.
-Yeah.
-They have a mouth.
-I should have brought
a picture,
'cause when Herman eats,
they look exactly
like Don Rickles.
-Really?
-Yeah. I'll send you a picture.
-Okay, great.
-Yeah.
-I have a lot of questions
about "Girls5eva."
We'll be right back
with more from Tina Fey.
-Probably more about lizards.
-And more about lizards.